hey folks Daniel Dwyer here from
GameSpot and this week the twitch app
launched on the Xbox one and it's
already been on the PlayStation 4 for a
little while so I thought what better
time to a compare and contrast the two
features on either console and answer
the question which one does it better
so I'm sitting here and my little little
boys bedroom playing my Killzone on the
PlayStation 4 and I'm thinking I want to
broadcast this so you guys probably own
so many machines already know what this
looks like all you have to do is hit the
share button pop over to broadcast
gameplay hit twitch or use Ustream we're
going to test a twitch now at the
options you have are more limiting than
the Xbox one and you can up to have the
comments and the chat on the screen and
whatever is on this on your television
is what's broadcast to twitch slight
difference with the Xbox one we'll get
into later and you can include your mic
audio and there's no option to turn off
party child in the PlayStation 4 either
and and then of course you can decide to
have the video from your PlayStation
camera if you want as well
usual stuff then social links and
channel name it's pretty bare-bones on
the PlayStation 4 but the best part is
it actually works pretty good and is
really easy to set up as well so this is
your general environment and when you're
twitching on the PlayStation 4 or all my
chat buddies are talking at the bottom
of the screen and give me information on
how many people are watching how many
comments there are and I'm up here in
the corner playing video games hi
everyone the ps4 streams at 960 by 540
at 30 frames per second at a bit rate of
about 1.7 megabytes per second and which
is pretty good not as good as the
Microsoft's console which we'll have a
look at in a second and one final note
about the ps4 is that by default and for
most users
there is no archiving of your streams so
if you go to twitch TV and log in your
streams aren't there on demand for
people to watch for some reason there is
a certain group of users for which this
is the case I am one of them but it's
not something that you can bank on and
not something that's the majority of
people are able to do okay here I am on
my xbox one play and some Call of Duty
goes something I want to stream this to
the wider world so what better way to do
that than opening up my twitch app which
I can do via the menu or I can do it by
sin
saying Xbox broadcasts Xbox broadcast
okay so twitch snaps over here to the
right and I've got my preview and I can
title it here for the sake of brevity I
will leave it as a untitled broadcast
but if we go into the settings has a
bunch of stuff here that is that not
available on the PlayStation 4
hopefully that guy doesn't shoot me I
keep keep walking buddy and you can
select where your picture picture goes
first of all at any corner of the screen
and you can turn off Kinect as you can
turn off the camera on and off on the
PlayStation 4 as well same sort of deal
with the microphone ever down here you
can set your own quality so if you have
a bit of an internet connection that can
be temperamental if you want you can set
it to low or medium and of course the
Xbox won't actually broadcast at a
higher resolution and bitrate and then
the PlayStation 4 at 1280 by 720 30
frames per second then a bit of 2.5
megabytes per second so that's a little
bit better than what you get on the on
the PlayStation 4 true 720 so I'm gonna
start my broadcast here and this is what
you're looking at while you're playing
so in here you've got your sort of a
preview hey everyone and you can see on
the side if you want you can double tap
the Xbox Guide button and head over to
the settings and tweak stuff from there
you cannot tweak the EM the oh and
there's murder this guy first died you
cannot tweak the quality settings while
you're in midstream but you can add
tweak a lot of other stuff move around
the picture-in-picture whatnot the
difference between doesn't the
PlayStation 4 in terms of your
experience is that you are not looking
at what the end user is watching so they
are watching you play and they're
watching the picture and picture so they
don't have the screen taking up with the
chat or with the information on the
right pane as you have into PlayStation
4 which kind of works a bit better and
means that the more screen real estate
for the actual game itself and it means
that a lot of your resolution is being
used just housing all that UI stuff the
Xbox one also enables archiving on
twitch.tv so if you want to see any of
your highlights and like murder in this
guy and you can head on over to the site
and all that stuff will be saved
it does delete after a while but if you
make sure to save it as a highlight hop
all right
uh-huh all right there did it if you
save it as a highlight it'll it'll it'll
retain inside of your your profile for
weeks and months to come
so that's twitch streaming on the Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 it seems that the
Xbox ones feature set is a bit stronger
its output to the high resolution it's
got a little bit more settings and it
also allows you to archive the stuff and
I think that the user experience for the
broadcaster is better however at what
you should always do when you're
streaming is ask your viewers what they
think as well because often times it'll
you know program will say that it's
doing something but for the people
watching it's something else so in
regards to that
make sure you sort of check out other
streams on twitch TV and see what you
think about those for continuing
coverage of twitch TV streaming on the
Xbox one and PlayStation 4
make sure you stay on gamespot comm and
I'm going to try and murder one more
person before this thing is come on come
on don't fit me now highlight real
highlight real moment I've got that